question for you so at the time George
Tenet was the director of CIA right
correct but he was not nominated by
President Bush he was nominated by
Clinton he was Clinton's CIA so why
would he keep him though isn't it why
would he not fire okay so let me kind of
play a little bit of a devil's advocate
so this is a game of Legacy game okay so
if you're playing the Legacy and it's a
very competitive game very very
competitive game in the darkest way and
there is no Leader's bulletin the only
leaders bulletin you have is who has a
worse reputation who has a bigger Legacy
who has a better Victory that's how you
compete in football touchdowns Super
Bowls Brady's got seven you don't he's
the goat you know Jordan's got six
LeBron you got four you know he played
1089 games and averaged 32 points a game
30 points a game you did not you were
1500 games the other day I watched a
statistic comparing John Stockton's uh
Legacy of uh consistency to LeBron James
do you know how many 82 season games
LeBron's hat one do you know how many
John Stockton said it was like 18 of see
that's just some some ludicrous number
on what he did like oh my God so we can
track Legacy based on stats okay now
LeBron's got Championship Stockton's got
zero so he can't brag about that part
but
why why the the
George tenet's loyalty isn't to Bush yes
you may say well no he's an American his
loyalties to the country and it's too
American it's this so part of it's like
it's inside so you're given Intel
the rest of us are watching the movie
Vice and you know you watch the movie
Vice you watch all these movies The W
there's so many movies that you read
about I've read decision points I've
read the book on the family what Bush
family stands for Prescott and what they
did and I gave him a gift from his uh
grandfather Prescott's one of the
buttons and about a bunch of different
things and I give him as a gift the
Legacy that you first go make your money
and then you take care of your family
and kids and then you give back to the
country and you run for office or
something like that's a very uh a lot of
things I pulled from that family's
Legacy to want to apply to my own family
but one why keep the same director of
CIA who was Nam who was nominated and
chosen by Democrat you're Republican why
not replace them with somebody's nobody
would say anything to you if you pick
somebody else and two you know when you
see a lot of uh the things that happen
with Vice and how well you know they
went to war because this was a great
business decision there's a lot of money
when you go to war you know look at Dick
Cheney and look at the the Donald's
Rumsfeld and look at some of the darkest
people in America and who they are and
et cetera Etc and
that's what the story is told right so
one why keep ten of two you know the
Legacy that we read about where the
motive behind it was money he kept
tenant because he viewed the CIA as a
non-political position it wasn't the
type of thing he needed a loyalist he
wanted somebody who was good in
intelligence and who had a steady hand
you think like would you advise let's
just say I become a president it depends
on who the person is if and he hit it
off with tenant during the transition he
liked tenet got it to a meshed
personality wise and so George Tenet was
a Democrat he worked for Senator David
Boren who was the chairman of the Senate
intelligence committee he was the chief
of staff on Capitol Hill to David Boren
President Clinton nominated George to be
the CIA director and Bush kept him and
again it was because he thought
continuity was important and it was not
a political position and he liked the
guy so again I mean the cia's
conclusions about wmd didn't begin on
George Bush's watch they had said the
same thing to the previous president to
president uh Clinton about Saddam
um as for legacy Etc
you know Bush never did anything for
legacy and I don't care if people
believe that or not he didn't he did it
because he thought it was the right
reason to protect America and he knew
some of the things he did were
controversial but he did them anyway
because he thought it was the right
thing to do for America
um any of this nonsense about money or
oil or any of that I mean doesn't that
fall into the same trolling vituperative
war criminal stuff we started talking
about earlier it's the same junk it's
the same excess it's the same extremes
speaking out in in a fashion that just
they let it rip and Bush's instructions
to me and the way Bush conducted himself
was to rise above it
he wouldn't let me go to the podium and
fight back on a lot of these things
because he didn't want to engage at that
level yeah and you know one of the
biggest criticisms I hear from president
Trump's supporters Sean Hannity included
and I've talked to Sean about this a lot
is Trump fought back you bushies mccains
Romney's you guys didn't know how to
fight back and you didn't fight back
Trump counter punches and this is a
legitimate difference inside the modern
Republican party how far do you go how
put how much punching should you do how
tough should you get and they said Bush
didn't fight back
is there a better balance like do you
think Bush should have fought more do
you think Trump fights too much is is
there a more moderate approach yeah I
think there's a balance I wrote a op-ed
in the Wall Street Journal when the
midterms for Donald Trump we're using a
football analogy I said the problem with
Donald Trump is every time he gains
yards going down the field he gets a
flag for Unnecessary Roughness or a late
hit so if he gains 100 yards he's
knocked back 65 yards from all these
penalties and I said you can't win the
game that way
um yeah I think there's more of a
balance I I think what happened in the
bush years particularly through the end
of the Bush era the White House staff
got tired
everything was just so tough things in
Iraq were so bad
Bush live people died they were too
tired to fight back and they thought
we're not going to get our message
across and I want to remind you back in
that era especially 2006 or so
we only had the mainstream media we
didn't have Twitter we didn't have
YouTube we didn't have social media we
couldn't go around the Press Bush didn't
have followers online
that didn't exist yet so we had to fight
through the New York Times The
Washington Post ABC NBC Fox was a very
different Fox back then so I just think
the White House staff said it doesn't
matter what we say the Press won't cover
us
so all these criticisms of bush matching
his low job approval stuck
so could he have fought back more should
he have fought back more
I was outside the White House at this
point I had fresher legs at that point I
would have loved to have fought more at
that point but for the people inside
they just thought it won't work I want
to show something can you pull this up
because I still want to go back to the
questions director of Center uh CIA okay
go all the way to the bottom go all the
way to the bottom all the way to the
bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom okay
go meaning to yeah go up a little bit
okay so uh uh George W bush okay stay
right there go a little lower on the
bush side
on the bush side yeah so if you look at
this uh he had three directors of CIA
okay one of which was George and he kept
him till all four specifically during
that era which was the issue and then he
replaced them with John okay but that's
not his guy but if you look at the uh uh
Clinton he had five on he had five
directors of CIA I interviewed James
Woolsey he says I don't even know why he
put me in the job because he never
talked to me we only talked twice
so he his director of CIA January 21st
1993 he picked him right stutterman uh
stadman stutterman so go up a little bit
to the next one if you keep doing the
same exact exercise uh that we're doing
George H.W bush it's his guy right
William Webster keep going up keep going
up keep going up Reagan his guy Jimmy
Carter his guy General Gerald Ford his
guy if you go to Nixon his guy if you go
to Lyndon Johnson his guy the only
person that didn't have the same
director of CIA as
the prior president as John F Kennedy
John F Kennedy kept it because it was
the same as go up a little bit uh as
Dwight Eisenhower so he says I'm just
going to keep it but I I don't know I
you know you you uh uh you're Elon Musk
you buy Twitter you don't keep the same
you know exact guys that you have
because they don't trust you they
probably don't even like you because in
the business world the people at Twitter
how it was ran before can't stand what
Elon stands for so Elon lets go of how
many people 3 750 people 50 percent of
Salesforce the the workforce what
happens to that 3750 they recruit the
other guys to quit you got another 1250
that resign you're like dude I don't
trust these guys I got to get somebody
anything that trust you know that aligns
with what I'm doing
so I think that my opinion I'm not on
the inside to say whether it's the right
move or not uh I don't know if I would
have done it that way that's my opinion
so what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red or black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people wore it in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]